we literally just bought a castle very
very recently and now we've exchanged
contracts and we've brought the family
to have a look round and to tall the
castle
it really is fabulous and we're just
getting all the quotes ready for the
works to begin next month so let's have
a look around
[Music]
my name is Ben my chicken language
chartered surveyor it's got a lot of
work still needs to be done
no dr. Bartis so there's gonna be some
hard craft that's gonna be required by
builders etc Architects designs surveys
that you need to do Sam sit and excited
about this I'm excited to see what he's
going to do with it
with this power team that he's got no
doubt and their feet in it in a year's
time you're 18 months time we'll be
walking around today again and you'll be
thinking wow what a great job this is
this is being so you'll see what I want
see what happens
I am soo on Samuels mum um something
else stepdad turned off from telling
with property it's brilliant
it's a lovely property loads of
character on there it's done really well
we've got it it's a really good price
and I'm really proud of him it's just so
good to have friends and family support
in supporting you in big decisions like
this so if I was completely on my own I
think I'd be absolutely scared but
having Russell my business partner in my
family
Ben who's my brother-in-law the surveyor
it's just really good to have that
support as well as our team but also
moral support
people cheering always great so thank
you guys for everything you've done and
you continue to do
I've got a lot of friends that have
missed out on big deals like this
because I haven't had all their ducks in
a row and I always say don't wait for
all the traffic lights to be on green
before leaving the house now in this
instance we actually before we signed
contracts and before we exchanged we had
we didn't have the full amount of money
for the for the castle
that's the money tied up and we signed
anyway just in faith that would be able
to get the money now I'm confident 100%
right now that we'll be able to get it
100% but I mean someone else could look
into the situation and say well you
haven't got any guarantees she's
definitely going to get it we haven't
been accepted to the bridging finance
officially yet we've got about half a
million in the bank but we're gonna need
a lot more to purchase the property and
then there's a refurb so we really are
just stepping out and I think that if
you're gonna if you're gonna think
anyway you might as well think big
someone once said so here we are and in
faith but I do believe that it's going
to come off from very confident we've
got a good Network we've got you know
we've got we have got money tied up I'm
sure about to put it out but my advice
would be don't wait until you've got
everything ready before you move because
if we'd have messed around and said oh
well it'd let us just keep keep waiting
and let's just wait to everything then
someone else would have bought the place
so that's what we've had to do anyway so
fingers crossed well it'll work out
we'll get the money in place but I'm
very confident in the world
[Music]
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time